you're wondering what's going on it's
not super windy right now we're calling
this sort of like the in-between day so
great live picture here from our camera
on top of the red rock resort because
this is one we used to show you if the
palm tree is really whipping around
there are a couple of breezes for sure
and we do have a couple of clouds all
the clouds are going to continue to
build throughout the day today i don't
think the wind is going to build up
throughout the day today we have 43
degrees as the official temperature at
reed international but
30s now up in the far northwest
centennial hills mountains edge i'm
guessing you're going to be dropping
into the 30s here before the sun comes
up
downtown you're 47 45 out at henderson
and also out at the air force base mount
charleston only a dusting of snow
yesterday and thanks to the viewer
riding in a couple of sprinkles reported
up in centennial hills and that's what
we're talking about maybe later today
tomorrow is your much better shot at
measurable rain we're talking about
maybe a quarter of an inch but we're
still on the here and now here with
nevada and beyond ely you're in for more
snow showers right now you're at 18.
caliente snow for sure tomorrow cedar
city right now you're at 28 tonifha at
19. so what's going on the temperature
not moving much today we're going to
stay in the 40s managed to make it to 53
yesterday normal high would be 56 but
get used to these highs in the 40s we
may try to inch it up to 50 before the
end of the year
speaking of 50 how about top wind gusts
angel peak that's on the mountains to
the north in the sheep range 63 miles an
hour red rock canyon 53 miles an hour
hoover dam close to 50. the top official
wind gust for the city at reed airport
was 45. so that's the storm that we're
kicking out right now but we're watching
for the next one already rolling down
the california coast
we think tomorrow is your much better
shot at rain and snow speaking of that
though there's plenty of it for the
dakotas through minnesota and it may be
a really nasty commute here for southern
iowa parts of missouri including st
louis thunderstorms but it turns into
snow and ice for central illinois
nothing like that here we're calling
today the partly cloudy in between day
46 for the high tomorrow storms late
tomorrow lingering into thursday we're
talking about maybe some snowflakes in
the higher elevations the foothills and
very windy last day of the year maybe 51
but we welcome 2022 at the freezing
temperature